please join me in welcoming our two new
executive producers of Supergirl our
showrunners Jessica Cuellar and Robert
Wagner sum up taking the drop I believe
a beeper gonna care what as Jon Jones
thank you David
perfect timing on rollin steel Melissa
Benoist
cheering Jordan Edwin shot
I'm applaud rook back and please welcome
a brand new person to the cast Odette
Annabelle's will be playing our villain
rain
[Applause]
hey guys the lovely Tyler Lee could not
make it today because she's with her
family right now going through a little
bit of a tough of a tough time so might
as well tweet her let her know that
we're thinking about her we love her we
miss her and just because she's not here
doesn't mean I'm not gonna fix my
standards don't you worry
anyway oh my gosh that teaser trailer
our first look at season three Melissa
Carl and Ruth was a mistake I got chills
up when I watched that the first time
she's typically one of the most
optimistic characters on TV what's going
through her mind right now what's
changed well I think you know the first
two seasons she's kind of been trying
the scales of balancing Cara Danvers and
Supergirl the reporter and superhero and
figuring out her identity and now where
we pick up in season three the scale is
leaning very heavily on Supergirl and I
think that's how she's coping with this
grief of you know sending her boyfriend
into a giant chasm in space Melissa are
we going to be seeing Cara really
leaning on her sister Alex or a little
bit of that support and that bond
through this tough time well I don't
think Alex would bless Cara not lean on
her
I think everyone that disabled is like
you know Martian Manhunter Hannah James
she had Lehman and they she has this
core group that you'll see kind of
spoken broader be like are you okay in
there
but people KDOT
she needs a hug um Robert and Jessica
I'm so excited that you guys are taking
the helm of pearl right now
now as you as acceptance these roles and
you took a look at the first two seasons
what would your goal approaching teeth
and three well we've been here all along
we just haven't been on the panel yeah
but um you know I think was to continue
to show and to follow the characters as
we put them in a bad fit at the end of
last season and just to move that
forward to tell stories that were honest
to them well the theme of season two
really was can Cara
Supergirl have it all love work as the
journalist superhero saving the world
and the theme of season three is what
does it mean to be human and all of the
characters will sort of be exploring
that question especially car well there
are some fresh faces let me do Super bro
this year and in order for me to talk to
the rest of the cast about certain
things I think that we need to tease
who's come in on to the show just anyone
kick us off last week's on the teaser we
have the brilliant Adrian Pasdar
at Morgan ed CC villain we have called
lovely joining the show foreign Jones
John Johnson's father we're very excited
that calm voice John John's and Justice
League animated series ooh very excited
to have another legacy cast join us we
also have Emma Tremblay playing the
character of Ruby and we have young
broke laws playing the teaching go
inside
and for those of you who are Jen the
Virgin Banshee by Petra what I want to
know is how much cash grants are we
going to be getting because we are very
excited tell you that cat brands will be
an episode 301 Wow and so we're
occurring on an alcohol season so Kat
Graham is not going anything can you
please have her share more scenes with
wind because I love their dynamic at the
end what kind of thing Johnny like
strong women Supergirl
Frode SP welcome series regular you're
our new big bad of the season rain in
the DC Comics she's known as a world
killer what can you tell us about her
yeah well first of all this rocks I mean
this is insane
I thought yet we know her origin she she
left Krypton and now is on earth the the
thing that's so great and so different
about this villain as opposed to you
know seasons 1 & 2 is that she has a
very specific agenda she's not out to
kill everybody she sees she also doesn't
just want to rule the earth she she has
her own reasons for dispensing her
justice that will unfold throughout
season
[Music]
who have you been sharing most of your
scenes with I however that information
Canon I know of spoilers for the world
well I can't say that I have worked with
Melissa a little bit I'm ready
Melissa how how she doing compared from
the other villains you've had to face
off with Robert but I'm really excited
for that one of the things that I love
so much in season two was getting to see
James really shake things up if you
thought that our vigilante Guardian with
that amazing shield Thank You Wynn you
look almost as good as cat grant sitting
in metal shoes chair but the one thing
is no one second I want even more are we
gonna be seeing jeans even like involved
even more with team Supergirl appear yes
we are we have amazing things in store
for James he's going to have a new love
interest I'll be very excited about it
and he's also
I have many choices in at Catco back to
his roots as a journalist and
photographer in a way that we haven't
seen him do fully they sort of harkens
back to Jimmy Olsen's character and
he'll continue in the guardian role
sometimes at the same time I will take
my camera and the Guardian what's funny
vitamins is helping to be amazed look
like wagon was looking forward to with
James's journey in this season what am I
most important lemon juice Oh looking
for in a lady because you can show I can
show some that that you haven't seen
from James in a while so it's like you
know it's you can show charm when you're
when you're having your eleventh you so
right now I'm a boss I'm beating people
up and you know yeah I want to be
sensitive want to be sensitive to I love
that we're going to be getting more win
and James Guardians team up what I want
to know if Cyrus still a part of the
picture or that still just a bromance
um no phrase really strangely she's
brought up the question don't worry uh
no yes no liar liar and winners still
together they're still dating they're
still going strong I have to imagine
that she you know occasionally goes out
with seem guardian but we haven't quite
figured if any of that out yet I don't
know these guys know way more than I do
but yeah we love to have a super baby
pretty cool I loved what winded with
James's Guardian suit are we going to be
seeing any upgrades
we're going to use me any upgrades to
the Supergirl food anytime soon
he has rollerskates combined so I should
get away
and after our gorilla field I you know
what I don't know if I'm going to get in
trouble for saying this for Andrew
Kreisberg did say as you want it to do a
change that it's all something very
different but I love my dude I really
love it now you'll get excited to put it
on of course I do when the Cape is so
healthy books home like I wanna keep
like I would never lose caper obviously
but I know it ain't broke don't fix it
the Cape worth is a very good air
conditioning system which serve people
however myself up I can make some really
cool noises of the leather it's like a
lemon Snuggie I did notice in our teaser
that you had even more blonde locks that
looks really nice okay I'll just kind of
them hey Chris although I'm here
I'm on it okay I was gonna say when we
last call on L he was escaping earth
something like that yeah
saying a careful goodbye to this girl
yes cheerful Oh
[Laughter]
cheerful he that's very opposite very
different but in true controlled fashion
his pod got knocked off-course it was
just real casually around well he is he
he's a note he was in a pod and I was in
space Robert just go help him out here
Robert you did you feel this I mean the
big on present here and Chris and when I
will return someone I was not going
anywhere is the central history of one
of the central mysteries of season three
so on the big the sort of big thing to
look forward to is monos return he
becomes the new Supergirl and it's very
tight spandex to fill but I think I'm
just the man for her job where she I've
been doing Jazzercise and they said they
wouldn't make new suit so even apple per
month for the thing father I can save
him I came to my fair that I wear
occasionally haiwan fit him so weird to
enjoy to advertise together Chris and
Melissa Monell and Cara otherwise women
caramels have a really interesting
journey and season two filled with a lot
of ups and downs
we now know that Monell will return do
you think that they can just pick up
where they left off or has too much
happened I mean I think I think the big
thing is is going to be what actually
happens come on Elle yeah the
circumstances I think would dictate that
yeah but what has been the most
rewarding part for you guys to play the
evolution of these two characters
together just the boys was really great
what was it was how they they started as
completely hating each other yes and
then they sort of loved each other but
it was secret and they're very very much
like 10 minutes yeah Oh secret from each
other yeah yes from each other but then
they like they like bicker like an old
married couple yeah what was fun for me
in terms of acting it was the humor we
got before that kind of moonlighting
relationship dynamic thumb butting heads
and then finding what they have in
common and roaming a good old Romeo and
Juliet David hi
we're getting to meet your father this
season
after the awesome I'm really excited and
very excited to be working with them
Carl Chan now so cool
he's a very cool a kind I love his work
and I'm just very excited to be working
with him on this show how would you
describe their father-son dynamic it's
not of me if you want again I think
there's going to be some complications
genre story with the last green Martians
so it's going to be extraordinary to
find that not only he'd be not the last
green Martian but the other one is your
father so it's going to be pretty deeply
emotional and I'm just very excited
about playing that toilet well
especially because you know John has
always been the father figure on this
show so it's gonna be interesting to see
how he reacts when his father comes to
town are we getting it's going to be
getting some like grandpa Zeo
but I hope so we can't get a grandfather
the show and I actually I do like I do
like the fact that I've become space
that seems like kind of like a buttface
that you're going to have a dad so
thanks grandpa
I don't think dad's gonna get a face
girl well I think I really enjoyed
working with which on the other four she
was great so anytime McMartin wants to
buy back in town it's okay by me
[Applause]
Katie congratulations on becoming a
series regular I watch a lot about
exempt sizing here so thank you very
much I loved your portrayal of Lena I
still do
I've got to know what has been the most
rewarding part for you to step into her
heels I think it's I think it's been
making such an iconic name I am you know
the Luthor mantel is good an easy one to
have and it comes with a lot of
preconceived notions and I am very glad
I've been able to dispel some of them
encourage some of them and fully make it
my own and I'm afford to doing more of
that we did get to see a little bit of a
tease in that trailer I think Nina
accidentally pissed off the wrong person
or he happened after his meal Oh what
can you tease about that dynamic moving
forward I'm about you guys I know this
is so hard for you but we have a whole
list of things we can say and I wouldn't
think we can so I'm running judgment
ahead I think we're all doing the same
so we will get there and I think what
was always good when you see two
powerful characters but hey and that is
always going to end up in really great
drama and we've had a couple of days now
with Adrian and he is like he's our he
is the nicest man that the most people
organized which is between the two and
it's quite disconcerting but from a
character point of view it's so in nice
when you see two equal - battling it out
so that's that's what's coming up but I
feel like on
well since we are going to be getting
more Lina what is something that you're
really excited to bring her um I'm
really excited that I hope in season 3
that the relationship that Lina and Cara
have sort of expands to to take in the
rest of the cast and the rest of the
cast of characters so they like I'm
really interested to see what happens
when Alex is thrown in the mix because
obviously both of us care about car as
well being but I would imagine
alex is slightly distrustful of the
loons there so that I think will be some
good to fuzzy you know I'm looking
forward to playing with everyone well
and that actually leads me to my next
question is one of the things that I
love so much about Supergirl is that it
shows a true-to-life
sister dynamic but it also has shown
with Cara and with Lena what a real
female friendship looks like or not it's
not girls being pitted against each
other not being happy they're not
nothing no idea about it they you
genuinely watch their friendship blossom
how important is it for you guys to be
able to show a friendship like that on
screen oh I'm completely react that you
get to be two women wholeheartedly
supporting each other that everything
they do that's rare there's no cockiness
there's no bitchiness there's no mean
girl it'll just honest friendship I
guess yes hunter honest even when they
disagree and ya think other than the wig
lies I don't know which is which but we
don't need to talk about but but ya know
with that you know friends share secrets
could this be the season that finally
everyone up here knows who Supergirl is
I mainecat grandma's now so I feel like
she always did always like I kind of
liked not knowing I think part of the
magic of the show is the fact that you
have people who don't know that they are
the same person you know and I think
that has to be me so dumb she doesn't
realize that her best friend
I mean seriously that allows the
superheroes to be vulnerable because she
doesn't have to be the superhero Rafina
she can be just human and I would be
really sad to miss that Agnes Ennis
what's fair
well Lena's mom has said to Cara when
she finds out she's going to be so upset
you actually think like how do you
imagine she would react um well we all
know Nina has no problem with aliens so
I don't think that would be the issue
but I think I think she will have a
problem with the fact that her best
friend had lied to her and I think she
would feel that it was another person
who didn't trust to do sir right
spectively she Walter laughing I think
that would upset her but I I don't think
she'd have any problem if you being
Supergirl just like you didn't tell her
we are going to open it up to the fans
in just a little bit but as I said
earlier just because Kyla and Floriana
could not make it with us today does it
means we weren't going to talk about
Stanford one of my all-time favorite
couple what can you tease when we last
left off Maggie popped the question we
didn't get me answer I'll excuse me Alex
off the questions imagine we didn't get
answered but Matt you did have a
gorgeous smile on their face what can
you tease about what's coming next
well I think most of you know that
Floriana is not able to return for the
full season which is a great
disappointment to us but that said we
have an amazing beautiful story to tell
and remaining episodes that is emotional
and modern and really honors the love
between these two women and she is
always welcome to come back to our show
whenever she's available we love Maggie
love Sanders and we are devoted to them
forever
so is that how you think Cara's going to
react when she founds when she finds out
that his sister pop the question I mean
she'll knew what car does for Alex and
support her no matter what and I don't
think she'll be surprised I don't think
any of them will be inscribed with Alex
this season we got some amazing footage
of her and that sizzle reel looking like
a badass as usual what a journey going
to be like in season 3 well her journey
like the others is kind of dealing with
her humanity and kind of she stood on
his left store where you've evolved her
character and she's fallen in love and
she'll be kind of weighing that against
or working the DAO and then struggling
with managing those two sides of the
list
you